and this is ingram angle from washington
tonight
the most unpatriotic president ever that
is the focus of tonight's angle
now going into the fourth of july
weekend the most patriotic time of the
year but of course
it's really a miserable time for the
left because they're embarrassed by our
people and our history
let's face it they hate most of our past
presidents including washington and
lincoln
everyone on mount rushmore they want
them all ripped down
and the last thing they want to do is
celebrate america's independence because
after all they don't want america to be
independent
so you think i'm exaggerating oh this is
just tv stuff well i'm not
think about who these people have become
think about what they truly believe
how they feel about american history
racism is real in america
and it has always been
xenophobia is real in america
and always has been
sexism too we should not be relying on a
history filled with racism and sexism
and hobophobia to determine our
fundamental rights today original sin of
slavery weaved white supremacy into our
founding documents and principles
what a horrible person and how do these
people feel about the actual people who
live here
the top domestic violent extremist
threat comes from racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists i want to
understand white rage and i'm white
white supremacy is a poison
it's a poison
running through it really is
running through our body politic and
it's been allowed to fester and grow
right in front of our eyes
he's talking about half the country
right there now how do they feel about
our being an independent country
foundation
of a rules-based international order
built out of the wreckage of two wars
world wars
violations of a core tenet of the
rules-based international order one of
our defining missions is to strengthen
the international rules-based order
oh my god okay let me define rules-based
international order for you
they're vague rules that exist only to
restrain and weaken the united states
and then empower countries
that enjoy free writing off of us or
china
the rules never never apply to china
which would never dream of doing
anything against its own self-interest
forget about it
now remember the abide administration
doesn't go overseas to defend american
interests oh no
they engage in multilateral talks to
advance global interests
american interests don't even come
second or third in biden world
why should we be trusted to make our own
policies or even
frankly even choose our own leaders we
should have to live under international
norms drafted by bureaucrats in europe
the eu they should run our domestic
policy our climate agenda our foreign
policy
and of course they should decide all hot
button cultural issues
and we know what they think
clearly it has massive impacts on
people's
thinking around the world it's a very
important decision i've got to tell you
i think it's a big step backwards i
think it's a big step backwards
of course biden rather than stand up for
our constitution and defend our system
even when he disagrees with some court
rulings
he piled on
america's better position
to lead the world than we ever have been
the one thing that has been
destabilizing is the outrageous behavior
of the supreme court of the united
states
on overruling not only roe v wade but
essentially challenging the right to
privacy
i'm confused
i thought that the one thing
destabilizing the world was president
putin in ukraine
of course but never talks about
president xi's forced enslavement of
millions of chinese or the extermination
of god knows how many dissidents in
china
but never speaks about how destabilizing
it is when china threatens taiwan ah
potatoes small potatoes
instead we saw joe biden standing in
madrid telling the world that what is
truly destabilizing is that some women
in states like mississippi can't get
more abortions
talk about outrageous behavior it's
beyond unpatriotic it's disgusting
but for him placating the far left by
trashing america abroad is far more
important than standing up for the
american people in front of the sneering
euro elites who are being guarded by the
way by soldiers from the same country
that they despise
we know this by the fact that they're
scrambling to do everything they can
to reverse our independence
they think our health policies should be
made by the who
they think our trade policy should be
made by the wto
that our foreign policy as i said should
be shaped by the europeans
and g over there in hong kong doing a
victory lap and these european fools are
complaining about the fact that
americans in all 50 states get to vote
on abortion
okay well send me a memo the next time
that boris and emmanuel lecture
president xi
about the lack of fundamental rights
over there don't hold your breath
in fact this was boris johnson today i
was up early and i decided to watch him
live at his press conference
after the g7 he was asked if the uk
needs to re-examine its relationship
with china now notice the equivocation
it's very important that we
remember that we have to uh we have a
huge economic relationship with china so
does every every country around that
table it is very very important that we
understand that china is a
is a a great country it's going to be a
gigantic fact of
the world's economy for a long time to
come so you need to
there has to be a balanced approach
a balanced approach but no step
backwards in china i guess only in the
united states that's real courage bojo
of course what biden should have been
doing in europe is standing up for
america not some vague notion of a
rules-based international order
it's simply staggering to think that
when we face the most dangerous
situation in modern times right now the
us is basically using virtually all of
its military efforts to prop up europe
while conceding the rest of the world to
china
and biden reassured the world not
americans
that there is no end to the amount of
money and weapons that we're going to be
sending to ukraine
how long is it fair to expect american
drivers and drivers around the world to
pay that premium for this war
as long as it takes russia cannot in
fact
defeat ukraine and move beyond ukraine
wait a second doesn't that all sound
familiar
well the media of course missed the boat
here
we're more united than ever
and with the addition of finland and
sweden we'll be stronger than ever we're
going to increase the nato border by 800
miles along the finnish russian border
no nato is not getting stronger america
is getting weaker though
and congrats joe by agreeing to nato
expansion you've just made things more
dangerous in europe
because putin is now threatening to move
nuclear weapons right to the border with
finland
so all this drama focused in one place
all this money billions and billions
diverted
it just gives china more running room
everywhere else in the world tucker's
been talking about what's happening in
south america it's happening in africa
it's happening on our doorstep it's time
for europe to step up and defend itself
we must insist on it president trump
tried
we have to reorient our own priorities
in a changing world
but instead biden chooses to drain our
wealth in europe while the leaders there
hate
us for everything we stand for
so this effectively means that we're
abandoning the entire rest of the world
to china which of course is funding the
war against ukraine by buying russian
oil oil and wheat
and remember that biden's on the verge
of dropping trump's tariffs against
china even though we've have now a near
record trade deficit with them
so stay with me this means that biden
has us indirectly funding the war in
ukraine
that we're trying to help ukraine win
it's twisted right
there is nothing patriotic about what
binding is doing in our foreign policy
or with our energy policy our trade
policy or at the border
all of it is designed to make america
less independent less prosperous and yes
less happy
so happy independence day
we're going to celebrate this one and
the one coming in the midterms and in
2024 and that's the angle hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else